From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi, sitting in for Ira Glass. Not too long ago, a few of us here on the show were talking about families, and how everybody has a role to play in theirs. And whatever your role is, it sort of becomes your identity. Like, this one's insular and really into books, or that one's the sensitive one who's quick to anger, or the little one's the sweetheart-- that sort of thing.
我是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是Bim Adewunmi，替Ira Glass主持。不久前，我们节目组的几个人在聊家庭，以及每个人在家庭中扮演的角色。无论你的角色是什么，它都会成为你身份的一部分。比如，这个是孤僻且爱读书的，那个是敏感且易怒的，或者最小的是个小甜心——诸如此类。
And the longer we talked about it, the more we began to notice a pattern. Sisters, in particular, often have very specific, very pithy elevator pitches about themselves and each other-- like my colleague on the show, Emanuele Berry.
我们聊得越久，越发现一个规律。尤其是姐妹们，对自己和彼此往往有非常具体、非常精辟的“电梯演说”式的评价——就像我节目组的同事Emanuele Berry一样。
OK, so I have three sisters. My oldest sister is Danielle. She's like, the rebel. She's the sister who moved out when she was a teenager.
好，我有三个姐妹。我大姐是Danielle。她就像是……叛逆的那一个。她是十几岁就搬出去住的那个姐妹。
Then, we have Elena. And she's like-- I guess you could say like, the diva.
然后是Elena。她就像是……我想你可以说她像是那种“天后”型的人物。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And then my youngest sister, Keanna, who's sort of like, the-- wants to have fun all the time-- like, little like, wild.
然后是我最小的妹妹Keanna，她有点像是……总是想找乐子……有点像，那种小野猫。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
But not like, too wild.
但也不是说，太疯狂那种。
[LAUGHS] I see.
[笑声] 我明白了。
She's fun. She's the fun one, I guess.
她很有趣。我想她是负责搞笑的那一个。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Yeah.
是的。
And when it comes to Emanuele's role, she said this thing, partly being funny, but also sort of seriously.
当谈到Emanuele自己的角色时，她说了这么一件事，部分是开玩笑，但也有点认真。
I'm the favorite. Yeah, I'm the favorite sister.
我是最受宠的。是的，我是最受宠的姐妹。
Huh.
哈。
The best.
最好的那个。
OK. [LAUGHS] See, that's-- that's overconfident right there.
好的。[笑声] 你看，这……这太自恋了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I was so sure that the story that my sisters tell about me is that I'm their favorite sister.
我非常确信，我姐妹们讲述关于我的故事就是，我是她们最喜欢的姐妹。
Amazing.
太神奇了。
Like, it is so clear to me that I am each of their favorite sister.
就好像我非常清楚，我是她们每个人最喜欢的姐妹。
OK, just checking.
好吧，只是确认一下。
No, I know it sounds like, unbelievably cocky. But I really don't think it's coming from a place of cockiness so much as like, in terms of our personalities, I'm the personality that like, can be the favorite. [LAUGHS] You know?
不，我知道这听起来，难以置信地狂妄。但我真的觉得这并不是出于自大，更多是因为在性格方面，我是那种能够成为“最受宠”的人。[笑声] 你懂吗？
Nothing you're saying is making it better.
你说的这些并没让情况好转。
No, I say that 'cause I think I'm-- I'm like, the peacekeeper. So like, I'm the one that gets along easiest with each of my sisters. Yeah.
不，我这么说是因为我认为我是……我是那种……和事佬。所以，我是最容易和每个姐妹相处融洽的人。是的。
You're like the character in the teen movie who's friends with the jocks, and the nerds, and the--
你就像青春电影里的那个角色，既是运动员的朋友，又是书呆子的朋友，还有……
Yes.
是的。
--the hipsters, and the cool Black girls, and all that stuff. That's you?
……时髦精的朋友，还有酷酷的黑人女孩的朋友，诸如此类。那是你吗？
Everyone, yeah, yeah, yeah, basically.
每个人都是，是的，是的，基本上是这样。
Amazing. OK, so Emanuele, I have to ask, in the interest of journalistic integrity--
太神奇了。好吧，Emanuele，我得问一下，出于新闻诚信的考虑——
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
嗯哼，嗯哼。
--would your sisters corroborate the very specific idea that you have, that you are their favorite?
——你的姐妹们会证实你那个非常具体的想法吗？就是你真的是她们最喜欢的那个？
I mean, yeah, I-- [LAUGHS] I think? I mean, I thought, but then I called my sisters.
我是说，会的，我……[笑声] 我想吧？我是说，我原本以为是，但后来我给姐妹们打了电话。
When I describe you to others?
当我向别人描述你时？
Yeah, like, is there a story that you tell about me, or is there like a, Emanuele is this sister?
是的，比如，有没有一个关于我的故事，或者说，有没有一种“Emanuele是这样的姐妹”的说法？
Well, I'm always like, my sister Emanuele, who's like, super smart. She has a super-cool job in New York.
嗯，我总是说，我的姐妹Emanuele，她超级聪明。她在纽约有一份超级酷的工作。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
It-- it does kind of come down to like-- this is so terrible, but Elena's the pretentious one, you're the ambitious one. Keanna's the one with the kid. [LAUGHS] I just always think of you as like, the family boss. Like--
这……这确实归结为……这太糟糕了，但Elena是那种装腔作势的，你是那种有野心的。Keanna是有孩子的那个。[笑声] 我总是把你当作……家庭里的老板。比如……
Mm.
嗯。
I don't know. If we were a mob family, you would be the boss of this family.
不知道。如果我们是黑帮家族，你就是这个家族的老大。
[LAUGHS] So when I asked my sister Elena-- she's the second eldest, she's right before me-- what's the story she tells to describe me--
[笑声] 所以当我问我二姐Elena——她就在我前面出生——她用什么故事来描述我时——
The first one that popped up, [LAUGHS] and I'm just like, it's not that flattering, but it's--
第一个浮现出来的，[笑声] 我只是觉得，这不太令人恭维，但它……
It's not that flattering?
不太令人恭维吗？
No, I mean-- it's just-- it was just the time that you punched me in the eye--
不，我是说……它只是……仅仅是你打我眼睛的那次……
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
--when we were like-- and you were like, four at the time, right?
……当时我们……你那时才四岁，对吧？
OK.
好的。
And we were playing Pocahontas.
当时我们在玩《风中奇缘》。
Yeah.
是的。
And I was the older sibling, and so I was going to be Pocahontas. You were younger than me.
我是姐姐，所以我当宝嘉康蒂。你比我小。
I mean, I always was playing some random side character or boy, always.
我是说，我总是扮演一些随便的路人角色或是男孩，总是这样。
And so you played her best friend. And I just remember-- and we were in a tent, too, because we had set up a tent in the living room, you know? And you were like, I want to be Pocahontas! And then you punched me in the eye.
所以你演她的好朋友。我还记得——而且我们在帐篷里，因为我们在客厅搭了个帐篷，你懂吧？然后你说，我想当宝嘉康蒂！然后你就给了我一拳。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So just-- just doing a tally-up--
所以，只是……做一个简单的总结——
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
嗯哼，嗯哼。
--of the responses of your sisters-- so, punched in the face, ambitious, the boss of the family, Mafia-style.
——关于你姐妹们的回应——脸上挨了一拳、有野心、家庭老大、黑手党风格。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
It's amazing to me how different those things are from the favorite.
这些评价和“最受宠”相差之大，让我感到惊讶。
I asked them for the first thing they think of, OK? [LAUGHS]
我让她们说出脑海中蹦出来的第一个念头，好吗？[笑声]
Right, so-- wait, hang on-- so favorite is not supposed to be the first, it's one of the things they say?
好吧，所以……等等，等一下……所以“最受宠”不应该是第一个，它是她们提到的事情之一？
I guess. Maybe it's just like, buried deeper than I anticipated in their like, minds, you know?
我想是吧。也许它只是埋得比我预想的深，在她们的……脑海里，你知道吗？
This is amazing backpedaling, and I love that.
这真是绝妙的圆场，我喜欢。
OK, so they didn't immediately say she was their favorite. But she doesn't mind. Instead, what struck Emanuele in these conversations was how it seemed like they all were telling the same stories, but with different entrance points, like a low-stakes Rashomon.
好吧，所以她们没有立刻说她是她们最喜欢的。但她并不介意。相反，Emanuele在这些谈话中印象深刻的是，她们似乎都在讲同样的故事，只是切入点不同，就像一场低配版的《罗生门》。
I mean, Danielle's story, right, is about me being like the mob boss of the family, or that's the sort of like, role that she holds me in. And the story I tell about her is that she left when she was a teenager.
我是说，Danielle的故事，对吧，是关于我像家里的黑帮老大，或者说这就是她看待我的角色。而我讲述她的故事是她十几岁就离开了。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And it's weird, because they're sort of connected in this way, where like, her leaving as a teenager kind of resulted in me having to take up some of that space, and be maybe more of a boss, right? So it's sort of like action and consequences, like we're telling the same thing.
很奇怪，因为它们以某种方式连接在一起，比如，她十几岁离开导致我不得不承担起一部分空间，变得更像个老大，对吧？所以这有点像是行为和后果，就像我们在讲述同一件事。
And then with my sister Keanna, the story she tells about me when we talked more is about how when we were in high school together, I tried to kick her off the basketball team.
然后是我妹妹Keanna，我们谈得更多时她关于我的故事是，我们在高中时，我试图把她踢出篮球队。
Hold on, that's a very casual way of saying something quite horrid. You what?
等等，这是一个非常随意的说法，用来形容一件相当可怕的事。你说什么？
Is it, though? Is it horrid? I was the captain of the basketball team, and she wasn't taking it seriously.
是吗？那很可怕吗？我是篮球队长，而她没把这当回事。
Explain.
解释一下。
She wasn't taking it seriously, and I was very serious about basketball. And she was just always goofing around, and she never wanted to run. She'd always, all of a sudden, like, have a cramp. And she couldn't do the suicides.
她没当回事，而我对篮球非常认真。她总是胡闹，从不想跑步。她总是突然间说自己抽筋了。她做不了折返跑。
I absolutely, 100%, love the air quotes. They really add something to the storytelling. And what's the story that you tell about her in relation to that?
我绝对，100%，喜欢这些引号。它们确实为故事增色不少。那么，关于那件事，你讲的是什么版本？
We went to Puerto Rico together for spring break when I was in college my senior year. And she like, fell hard for this guy. And she kept like, disappearing, and I didn't know where she was.
我大四那年春假我们一起去了波多黎各。她疯狂爱上了一个男人。她总是玩消失，我不知道她在哪里。
And we got in this huge fight where we were like, screaming drunk in the streets at each other. And she's like, I'm an adult! And I'm like, I'm calling mom and dad!
我们大吵了一架，在大街上醉醺醺地对着彼此大喊大叫。她说，我是个成年人了！我说，我要给爸妈打电话！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, but at its core, it's sort of about how Keanna is always about-- Keanna wants to have fun. Like, at the end of the day, that's what it's about for her.
是的，但核心其实是关于Keanna总是……Keanna想要找乐子。归根结底，这就是她想要的。
Right, and you're sort of the fun marshal?
对，而你是那种……快乐纠察队？
A little bit, yeah. I mean, I got to keep her in line.
有一点，是的。我是说，我得让她守规矩。
Yeah, like a boss. Like a mob boss.
对，就像个老板。就像个黑帮老大。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm the boss, and like, Keanna's the wild one. And we each sort of have like, these labels, right? But they're also kind of outdated.
我是老板，Keanna是疯狂的那一个。我们每个人都有某种标签，对吧？但它们也有点过时了。
Like, my sister Keanna is like, a mother. And I don't think she can drink a half a glass of wine without passing out anymore-- like a very-- very different than Puerto Rico Keanna.
比如，我妹妹Keanna现在是位母亲。我觉得她现在连半杯红酒都喝不完就会昏睡过去——和波多黎各那个Keanna非常、非常不同。
Sure.
当然。
But you sort of like-- right? You get stuck with these roles from childhood. Like, we're a weird ecosystem or something like that. And we all have a place. So like, she's the fun one, so I can't be the fun one.
但你就是……对吧？你被童年留下的这些角色卡住了。我们就像一个奇怪的生态系统之类的。我们都有自己的位置。所以，她是负责搞怪的，我就不能是负责搞怪的。
Right, you can't have two letter As--
对，你不能在字母表里有两个A字母——
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
--in the alphabet. Even though you might make similar sounds, I feel like you're all such distinct letters.
——即使你们可能发出相似的声音，我觉得你们都是如此独特的字母。
Yeah.
是的。
And each one has to kind of fit in.
而且每个人都得找到自己的位置。
Yeah, in this sort of like, world that we've created as sisters.
是的，在我们作为姐妹创造的这个世界里。
Unlike Emanuele, I only have one sister. But if I had to define myself-- like, if someone asked me about the foundational underpinning of my identity, among all the many things I could say-- that I think in paragraphs, or that I tend to cheerfulness over melancholy-- before all of that, the thing that I would say is that I'm Ade's little sister. She's three years older than me, the kindest person I know, my best friend. I love her like she's me.
和Emanuele不同，我只有一个姐妹。但如果我必须定义自己——比如，如果有人问我身份的基础是什么，在我能说的众多事情中——比如我喜欢段落式思考，或者比起忧郁我更倾向于开朗——在那一切之前，我会说我是Ade的小妹妹。她比我大三岁，是我认识的最善良的人，我最好的朋友。我爱她，就好像她是我自己一样。
And when I was small, I wanted more than to be like her. I kind of wanted to eat her up, just consume her. I was obsessed with her, but like, in a healthy way.
小时候，我不只是想变得像她。我甚至想吃掉她，就是完全占有她。我迷恋她，但就像是以一种健康的方式。
We created this dense, self-contained world together as kids. One example of it was Funky Funky Funky Radio, a radio station universe that we made up and recorded onto cassettes that we lost years ago. We did news, and current affairs, and human interest stories, and sports-- specifically horse racing, with a twist that in this world, the horses could talk, and they all had very different personalities. My sister was basically the station manager. She directed our work like she directed my life at that age.
我们小时候一起创造了一个紧密、独立的世界。其中一个例子是“Funky Funky Funky电台”，那是一个我们编造的广播电台宇宙，我们把它录在卡带上，而那些卡带多年前就丢了。我们做新闻、时事报道、人文故事和体育——特别是赛马，还要加点料，在这个世界里，马会说话，而且它们都有非常不同的个性。我姐姐基本上就是电台经理。她指导我们的工作，就像她在那个年纪指导我的生活一样。
Funky Funky Funky Radio was completely for us. We'd play it back to ourselves, and give notes on what we could do better next time. Sometimes, we played it to our dad, but it wasn't for him. It was an exercise in sisterly world building.
“Funky Funky Funky电台”完全是我们自己的。我们会回放给自己听，并记录下下次可以改进的地方。有时我们放给爸爸听，但那不是为了他。这是姐妹间构建世界的一种练习。
Being a younger sister is how I move through the world. I'm the second one, the younger one, the littler one. I'm aware of all the cliches-- that they're annoying, attention hogs, the ones who get to mess up-- a whole box of behaviors. Even so, with the noted exceptions of Amy March and Lydia Bennett, I reserve my biggest love for almost every literary or pop culture little sister-- Serena over Venus, Marianne Dashwood over Elinor, Sasha Obama over Malia.
作为一个小妹妹，是我在这个世界上行进的方式。我是第二个，年纪更小的，更小的那个。我知道所有的陈词滥调——她们很烦人，爱抢风头，是那种可以随心所欲犯错的人——这一整套行为。即便如此，除了Amy March和Lydia Bennett，我对我几乎所有的文学或流行文化中的小妹妹都怀有最深的喜爱——比如Venus Williams的小妹妹Serena，Elinor的妹妹Marianne Dashwood，Malia的妹妹Sasha Obama。
I'm the second of four, so that means I'm a big sister, too, to two brothers whom I love very much, Demola and Dapo. But that fact, the fact that I am also two other people's older sister, is so secondary to that first, fundamental identity that I have. I'm the little sister.
我是四个孩子里的第二个，这意味着我也是个大姐姐，我有两个弟弟，Demola和Dapo，我非常爱他们。但那个事实，即我也是另外两个人的大姐姐，对于我拥有的那个最初、最根本的身份来说，是次要的。我是小妹妹。
Maybe it's because my sister knew me before I really knew myself. I got to meet my brothers when they arrived in this world. But Ade, she was already a fact.
也许是因为我姐姐在我真正认识自己之前就认识我了。我看着我的弟弟们降生到这个世界上。但Ade，她已经是一个既定事实。
She's the most constant thing in my life. I've never known a world without her. I can't imagine it, and I don't want to.
她是我生命中最恒久的存在。我从未经历过没有她的世界。我无法想象，也不想想象。
Today's show is about that world that can exist between only sisters-- the worlds they build together, and the things that could knock those worlds off their axis. We have two stories today about the bonds between sisters, and how they get broken and fixed, or not. Stay with us.
今天的节目是关于姐妹之间独有的世界——她们共同构建的世界，以及那些可能将这些世界击碎的事物。今天我们有两个关于姐妹羁绊的故事，关于这些羁绊如何破裂、修复，或者无法修复。请继续收听。
Sister Act One: Cindy and Dayana. We start today with sisters Cindy and Dayana Carcamo. They're close, but recently, they've been struggling with this thing that happened when they were very young. For the first part of their childhood, they didn't know each other at all. Here's Cindy.
姐妹篇第一部：Cindy和Dayana。我们从Cindy和Dayana Carcamo这对姐妹开始。她们很亲密，但最近，她们一直在为小时候发生的一件事而挣扎。在她们童年的前半段，她们根本不认识彼此。这是Cindy的讲述。
My family is from Guatemala. My sister Dayana was born there. She lived there for years, far away from me and my parents. I was born in LA. When we were little, Dayana believed that explained one difference between us.
我的家人来自危地马拉。我姐姐Dayana在那里出生。她在那里住了很多年，远离我和我的父母。我是在洛杉矶出生的。小时候，Dayana认为这解释了我们之间的一个差异。
I thought you were very American-looking.
我觉得你长得非常像美国人。
What she means by American-looking is that I looked white.
她所说的“像美国人”是指我看起来像白人。
At one point, I remember thinking that if you were born in China, you would look Chinese. And if you were born in America, you-- yeah, I remember thinking like that. So it could be that. You know, I thought she was-- she was born in the US, so she was very American-looking. And I was like, wow, she looks really different than the way I look.
有一次，我记得我在想，如果你在中国出生，你就会长得像中国人。如果你在美国出生，你……是的，我记得我是这么想的。所以可能是那样。你知道，我想她是……她在美出生，所以她看起来很像美国人。而我当时想，哇，她看起来和我真的很不一样。
In Guatemala, like a lot of places, whiter skin is considered prettier. My lighter skin became a thing for us growing up. Like, one time, a family friend, Ricardo, came to visit. He looked like the famous '80s singer, El Puma.
在危地马拉，和很多地方一样，皮肤较白被认为更漂亮。我较浅的肤色在我们成长过程中成了一个话题。比如，有一次，一个家庭朋友Ricardo来访。他看起来像著名的80年代歌手El Puma。
So I remember him making a comment one time. I remember exactly where we were. We were at the entry of the house.
我记得他当时发表了评论。我清楚地记得我们当时在哪里。我们在屋门口。
Yeah, and I remember him saying, oh, Cindy, you're-- you're so pretty. Oh, look at you. And then I remember him telling me, oh your sister's so pretty. Oh, it's a good thing you're smart. I'm glad you're smart.
是的，我记得他说，噢，Cindy，你……你真漂亮。噢，看你。然后我记得他跟我说，噢，你姐姐真漂亮。噢，幸好你很聪明。我很高兴你很聪明。
And I was like-- I was like, yeah, I am smart. And I was like, OK, that's kind of odd. But I knew-- I knew very well, though, why you were prettier than me.
我当时就想……我就想，是的，我很聪明。然后我就想，好吧，这有点奇怪。但我很清楚，为什么你比我漂亮。
To me, she was always so beautiful and great, so quick-witted, so good at managing everything, at reading a room. She always knew what to say.
对我来说，她总是那么美丽、伟大，那么机智，那么善于处理一切，善于察言观色。她总是知道该说什么。
For as long as I can remember, I wanted to be like her. She was the responsible one, I was a space cadet. She was the neat one, I was the messy one. At one point, she put tape down the middle of the bedroom and told me to keep my mess on my side.
从我记事起，我就想变得像她。她是负责任的那个，我是个白日梦患者。她是爱整洁的那个，我是邋遢的那个。有一次，她在卧室中间贴了胶带，让我把我的杂物都放在我那边。
All those things, I always thought that's just who she is, how she is-- rigidly organized, high achieving, her obsession with being perfect, always wanting to please. But while we were talking, it dawned on me for the first time that I had it all wrong. A lot of those traits had to do with her being separated from our parents.
所有这些，我一直认为这就是她的本性——极其有组织、高成就，她对完美的执着，总是想要取悦他人。但当我们谈话时，我第一次意识到我全搞错了。很多这些特质与她曾与父母分离有关。
(TEARING UP) No, because I didn't want to disappoint them. Yeah, I knew, you know, I had to be a good girl. And I had to listen to-- I had to listen to whatever they said, and I had to impress them. Because I didn't want to be sent back.
（哽咽）不，因为我不想让他们失望。是的，我知道，你知道，我必须做一个好女孩。我必须听……无论他们说什么，我都要听，我必须给他们留下好印象。因为我不想被送回去。
By sent back, she's talking about being sent to Guatemala. My mom and dad came to the US when Dayana was just a baby. My mom was a teenager. They were crossing illegally, and she worried it was too dangerous to bring her. It seemed irresponsible.
关于“送回去”，她说的是被送回危地马拉。我爸妈在Dayana还是个婴儿时就来了美国。我妈妈那时还是个少女。他们是非法越境的，她担心带她过来太危险。这看起来很不负责任。
So they left Dayana with her grandmother, Chita. It was a cushy setup-- they had a housekeeper who basically waited on Dayana. They lived in a nice neighborhood.
所以他们把Dayana留给了她的祖母Chita。那是个相当优越的环境——他们有个管家，基本上是照顾Dayana的生活。他们住在一个不错的社区。
And anyway, my parents assumed they'd be back for her soon. She wouldn't end up joining them for years. It's only now that I'm beginning to put together a more complete picture of why that was, and how much it shaped Dayana and our family.
无论如何，我父母以为他们很快就会回来接她。直到多年后她才加入他们。直到现在，我才开始拼凑出关于为什么会这样，以及这在多大程度上塑造了Dayana和我们的家庭的更完整的图景。
For a long time, I knew the basic facts-- Dayana lived the first years of her life in Guatemala without my parents, and then she came home. But I never knew the full story. What was it really like for her? How did it affect her? What did she imagine about her life in LA?
很长一段时间里，我知道基本事实——Dayana在没有父母的情况下在危地马拉度过了生命的前几年，然后她回家了。但我从不知道完整的故事。对她来说，真实情况是什么样的？这对她有什么影响？关于在洛杉矶的生活，她是怎么想象的？
Sometimes, you can be so close to people, but this is the kind of thing you don't ask about.
有时，你可以和人非常亲密，但这正是那种你不会去询问的事情。
What was your idea of what mom and dad were like?
你当时对爸妈的印象是什么样的？
I pictured her as this almost like, professional career, beautiful woman. I knew she worked full-time. And I remember them saying something about how she used to like, design like, fabrics. So I thought that was pretty glamorous.
我把她想象成那种专业的、事业有成的美丽女性。我知道她全职工作。而且我记得他们说过她以前如何喜欢设计面料之类的。所以我认为那非常迷人。
And I remember the way she dressed. Like, she wore these kind of fitted shirts. And I remember looking at her and thinking, wow, she has such a beautiful body. I want to be like her.
而且我记得她的着装方式。比如，她穿那种紧身衬衫。我记得看着她想，哇，她的身材真好。我想变得像她。
You know, she had this like, cute butt. And I was like, oh my gosh, I don't have a butt. I want to have a butt like mama.
你知道，她有那种可爱的屁股。我就想，天哪，我没有屁股。我想拥有像妈妈那样的屁股。
Dayana told me that, during the years apart, she would imagine what it would be like when she finally joined us.
Dayana告诉我，在分别的那些年里，她会想象最终和我们团聚时会是什么样子。
Like, a lot of-- a lot of hugs, telling me that I was very special, that they loved me. And I thought I was going to be very special coming here, you know, to the US, because they were finally going to have me. And I thought I was going to be like, on this throne type of thing, because they had missed me so much. And they were going to want to be with me.
比如，很多的拥抱，告诉我很特别，他们很爱我。我想我来到这里会很特别，你知道，来到美国，因为他们终于要接我了。我想我会坐在某种宝座上，因为他们太想我了。而且他们会想和我在一起。
My parents did miss Dayana desperately. While Dayana was in Guatemala, they sent her boxes full of toys, clothes, and American candy like Snickers bars and Wrigley's chewing gum-- stuff that was pricey or hard to find back then. My mom told me after they were separated, she kept having this dream where Dayana was on a mountain that she couldn't reach.
我父母确实非常想念Dayana。当Dayana在危地马拉时，他们给她寄去满满一箱的玩具、衣服和美国糖果，比如士力架和箭牌口香糖——那些在当时昂贵或很难找到的东西。我妈妈告诉我，他们分开后，她一直做着同一个梦，Dayana在一座她无法抵达的山上。
She became deeply depressed. It runs in our family. But it's hard to know whether mom's started because of the separation, or if it was there all along, and the separation made it worse.
她变得极其抑郁。这在我们家族中有遗传。但很难知道妈妈的抑郁是因为离别开始的，还是它一直都在，而离别加剧了它。
The first time my mom was able to visit Guatemala after the separation, Dayana was two or three. She hadn't seen her for over a year. Now, she was meeting her as a toddler. This was before I was born.
我妈妈第一次能去危地马拉探亲时，Dayana两三岁。她已经有一年多没见她了。现在，她是以一个蹒跚学步的孩子身份见到她。那是在我出生之前。
My mom showed up with a suitcase full of outfits and toys for Dayana. And when she got to the house, Dayana sort of ignored her. She'd rather hang out with Chita, or her Aunt Estella, or Uncle Yembi. At one point, my mom scolded her for something, and Dayana responded with, tu no me creaste-- you didn't raise me. But she couldn't pronounce her R's, so the way the story's always told in my family, she said, tu no me cli-aste.
我妈妈带了一个手提箱，装满了给Dayana的衣服和玩具。当她到达房子时，Dayana有点无视她。她宁愿和Chita，或者她的姨妈Estella，或者叔叔Yembi在一起。有一次，我妈妈因为某事责骂了她，Dayana回答说：“tu no me creaste”——你没有养育我。但她发不出R的音，所以正如我家一直流传的故事那样，她说的是，“tu no me cli-aste”。
My mom felt rejected. She says, looking back, she knows she shouldn't have felt that way. But she was so young. She was only 20.
我妈妈感到被拒绝了。回首往事，她说她知道自己不该有那种感觉。但她太年轻了。她才20岁。
Meanwhile, her mom, Chita, was emphatic that Dayana should stay. She cried. She told my mom, I'm attached to her now. Don't take her away.
与此同时，她的母亲Chita坚持认为Dayana应该留下。她哭了。她对我妈妈说，我现在和她有感情了。别把她带走。
By the end of the visit, my mom decided she couldn't tear Dayana away from Chita and a family she did know. So she came back to the US alone, without Dayana. She left the suitcase full of toys behind.
那次访问结束时，我妈妈决定她无法把Dayana从Chita和一个她熟悉的家庭中强行拉走。于是她独自回到了美国，没有带Dayana。她把装满玩具的箱子留在了那里。
That scene-- mom going to get Dayana, Dayana staying in Guatemala-- that turned into something that happened over and over. It happened so many times that both Dayana and my mom have lost track. It was always the same-- mom would come with the intention of bringing Dayana back with her, Dayana didn't really want to be with her, Chita would cry, and mom couldn't bear to take Dayana away from her.
那一幕——妈妈去接Dayana，Dayana留在危地马拉——反复发生。它发生了太多次，以至于Dayana和我妈妈都记不清次数了。总是这样——妈妈带着要把Dayana接回去的意图来，Dayana并不真想和她在一起，Chita会哭，而妈妈不忍心把Dayana从她身边带走。
I'd heard that story a lot growing up. The back-and-forth tormented my mom for years. I asked her to talk to me for the story, but she said no. She can't talk about this without crying, and that embarrasses her.
我长大过程中听过很多次那个故事。那种来来回回折磨了我妈妈很多年。我请她为这个报道和我谈谈，但她说不。她无法不流泪地谈论这件事，这让她感到尴尬。
Until now, it never occurred to me to ask Dayana how all this felt to her. Dayana told me the constant thing she remembers is my parents would come to take her, and the adults would start arguing. And it was really confusing. She wanted to go with mom and dad, but she didn't want to leave Chita behind, either.
直到现在，我从未想过问Dayana这一切对她来说意味着什么。Dayana告诉我，她记得最清楚的一件事就是我父母来接她，大人们就开始争吵。这真的很令人困惑。她想和爸妈走，但她也不想把Chita留下。
And the adults around her weren't helping. One day, they'd tell her, you're leaving. And then they'd tell her, never mind, you're staying. That was the kind of detail about Dayana's childhood that I didn't know most of my life.
周围的大人们也没帮上忙。有一天，他们告诉她，你要走了。然后又告诉她，算了吧，你留下来。这就是关于Dayana童年的细节，我大半辈子都不知道。
And I didn't know this part, either. At one point, my parents turned to Dayana and asked her point blank, so how about it? Do you want to come live with us in the US? And Dayana was like, sure. She was around four.
我也不知道这一部分。有一次，我父母直接问Dayana，那么怎么样？你想来美国和我们住吗？Dayana说，当然想。她那时大约四岁。
But then I remember the next day, Tia Estella saying, you shouldn't go. We love you here. You should really just stay here with us. Why do you want to go with them? They left you anyway, and-- so it was that type of conversation.
但后来我记得第二天，姨妈Estella说，你不该去。我们在这里爱你。你真的应该就留在这里和我们在一起。你为什么要跟他们走？反正他们抛弃了你，而且……就是那种谈话。
And then I remember mom and dad asking me again, and me saying no. And then I remember mom and dad being very upset about that.
然后我记得爸妈又问了我一次，而我说不想。然后我记得爸妈为此非常难过。
To this day-- this comes up in my family, by the way, that Dayana said she wanted to stay. My parents bring it up whenever Dayana asks, why didn't you bring me? It's become this ongoing refrain.
直到今天——顺便说一句，这在我的家庭里经常被提起，Dayana说她想留下。每当Dayana问，为什么你们没接我？我父母就会提起来。这成了持续不断的重复。
They'll say, you said no. We asked you, remember? It's gone on for years.
他们会说，是你自己说不的。我们问过你，记得吗？这已经持续了很多年。
As a reporter, I've covered family separations. I've covered US immigration policy for more than a decade, most recently for the Los Angeles Times. And in my job, I've covered their reunifications-- families in airports or at the border hugging each other and crying, teenagers and moms, dads and toddlers, with toddlers looking stoic and distant-- the whole range. I'm the reporter who goes up to them and asks them how they're feeling.
作为一名记者，我报道过家庭离散。我报道美国移民政策十多年了，最近是在《洛杉矶时报》。在我的工作中，我报道过他们的团聚——机场或边境上家庭成员拥抱、哭泣，青少年和母亲，父亲和蹒跚学步的孩子，孩子们看起来木讷而疏离——各种各样的情况。我就是那个走过去问他们感受如何的记者。
For a lot of people, I think these scenes look like an ending, the conclusion of these stories. But I know they're not. They're just the beginning.
对很多人来说，我想这些场景看起来像是结局，是这些故事的终点。但我知道不是。它们只是开始。
This moment, when a child is returned to their parents, I'm always thinking, the next part, that's the hard part. My sister still remembers the exact date that she finally joined my parents in the United States-- December 7, 1982. She was eight, I was three. My parents were legal residents by then.
这一刻，当孩子被送回父母身边，我总是在想，下一部分，那才是最难的部分。我姐姐还记得她最终加入美国父母身边的确切日期——1982年12月7日。她八岁，我三岁。我父母那时已经是合法居民了。
Dayana came with Chita-- mom thought it would be easier that way-- and they came for a long visit. At the end, the plan was, Dayana stays. And this time, Chita relented. Dayana was finally here for good.
Dayana和Chita一起来的——妈妈觉得那样会更容易些——她们来进行了长期的访问。最后，计划是Dayana留下。这一次，Chita妥协了。Dayana终于留下来了。
Until I started asking her about this recently, I'd always imagined the years of separation were the hardest part for Dayana. But that wasn't true at all.
直到我最近开始问她这些，我一直以为离别的那些年对Dayana来说是最难熬的。但这完全不是事实。
I didn't know my parents. And I didn't know how they were going to treat me. I didn't-- I really didn't know them. So it was almost like I was with strangers.
我不认识我的父母。我也不知道他们会怎么对待我。我……我真的不认识他们。所以就好像我和陌生人在一起一样。
Back in Guatemala, Dayana grew up with aunties and cousins who lived steps away-- a whole network of people who doted on her. There was a refrigerator full of homemade ice cream, and Chita would let Dayana grab what she wanted. It must have been so weird for her, having to navigate a whole new set of rules and ways of living, having to decipher everything, and all of us.
在危地马拉，Dayana和生活在几步之遥的姨妈、表亲们一起长大——一个全心全意爱护她的人际网络。那里有装满自制冰淇淋的冰箱，Chita会让Dayana随意拿取。她不得不适应一整套新的规则和生活方式，不得不去解读每一件事和我们所有人，这一定让她感到非常奇怪。
I remember feeling really lonely. I missed Yembi a lot-- my uncle. And then, of course, Chito-- grandpa-- I missed him a lot.
我记得感到非常孤独。我非常想念Yembi叔叔。当然还有爷爷Chito，我非常想念他。
I remember I had-- mom and dad bought me a lot of like, stuffed animals. And I remember I named all of them. So one of them was like, Paola. One of them was Yembi. One of them was Chito. Like, they all had a-- all had a name.
我记得我有……爸妈给我买了好多毛绒玩具。我记得我给它们都起了名字。其中一个叫Paola。其中一个叫Yembi。其中一个叫Chito。它们都有……都有个名字。
I remember feeling lonely all the time.
我记得我一直感到孤独。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Yeah, I mean, it lasted for-- you know, it lasted, gosh-- I think I started to feel-- feeling more comfortable with everything probably in junior high.
是的，我是说，这持续了……天哪……我想我大概在初中时开始感到……对一切感到更舒适了。
Yeah, it's a long time.
是的，时间真的很长。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
This is the first time I heard this. And it crushed me. It's hard for me to hear this, to hear Dayana dealing with this in such a little kid way.
这是我第一次听到这些。这让我心碎。听到Dayana以那种小孩子的方式处理这些，这让我很难受。
She never seemed like a kid to me when we were little. She was so competent. She was so good at school-- straight A's, always so practical.
在我们小的时候，她看起来一点都不像个孩子。她非常有能力。她在学校表现很好——全A，总是非常务实。
She didn't like to play. I had an imaginary friend growing up, and she very rationally was like, that doesn't make sense. I've always felt she was a grown-up from the beginning, but of course, she wasn't.
她不喜欢玩。我小时候有个想象中的朋友，她非常理性地说，那毫无意义。我一直觉得她从一开始就是个大人了，但当然，她不是。
She felt insecure, like an outsider. So she made a plan to try to fit in, to make herself indispensable to our family. Here's what she did every day-- she made her bed and mine, she dressed me in the morning, she made our lunch for school, she helped me with my homework, she washed dishes after dinner, and on the weekends, she helped my mom clean the bathroom. This was the stuff Toya did back in Guatemala-- the housekeeper.
她感到不安全，像个局外人。所以她制定了一个计划，试图融入，让自己成为家庭中不可或缺的人。这就是她每天做的——她铺好了她的床和我的床，早上帮我穿衣，准备我们的学校午餐，辅导我的作业，晚饭后洗碗，周末帮妈妈打扫浴室。这些都是Toya在危地马拉做的事——那是当时的女佣。
Dayana did all of this because, in her mind, the stakes were so high. She really did think she'd be sent back. I had no idea. And this wasn't just some little kid thought she had. She told me that the adults warned her that might happen.
Dayana做这些是因为，在她心中，风险太高了。她真的以为会被送回去。我完全不知道。而且这不只是小孩的想法。她告诉我大人们警告过她可能会发生那种事。
Just because I remember Chito telling me that I had to be really good, or-- because if I wasn't good, they could send me back.
我只记得Chito告诉我，我必须表现得很好，否则……因为如果我不乖，他们可能会把我送回去。
Ugh.
哎。
Yeah. But--
是的。但是……
Dayana says she heard this from our Chita, too. My mom was always the hardest relationship for Dayana to figure out. It didn't help that her mom's depression continued and went undiagnosed for years. So life with mom could be unpredictable.
Dayana说她从我们的Chita那里也听到了这些。我妈妈和Dayana的关系一直是最难处理的。她妈妈的抑郁症持续多年且未得到诊断，这毫无帮助。所以和妈妈一起生活可能是不可预测的。
Anything would set her off. My mom was so fragile. She seemed constantly aggravated and anxious. And she was usually unsatisfied with anything Dayana did.
任何事都能让她爆发。我妈妈太脆弱了。她看起来总是烦躁不安。而且她通常对Dayana做的任何事都不满意。
They'd argue over the temperature of the dish water, or the settings on the dryer, Dayana being a little late when she picked her up from school. Always hanging around was the hurt my mom felt from when Dayana had refused to come to the US back when she was little.
她们会为洗碗水的温度、烘干机的设置、Dayana放学接她稍微晚点而争吵。一直悬在她们头顶的是妈妈因为Dayana小时候拒绝来美国而感到的创伤。
She would just get really mad, and just, you know, say things like, I shouldn't have come here, or-- I'd just do things to upset her. Ever since I came to this country, I would just upset her, and I would do things on purpose to upset her.
她会变得非常生气，只是，你知道，说些话，比如，我不该来这里的，或者……我就是会做些事来惹她生气。自从我来到这个国家，我就是会做些事惹她生气，我就是会故意做些事惹她生气。
She said that to you, that you shouldn't have come here? Do you remember that? I mean-- or did--
她对你说过吗，说你不该来这里的？你记得吗？我是说……还是说……
Yeah, yeah--
是的，是的……
--was that something she said all the time?
……那是她经常说的话吗？
No, not all the time, but she would just say, you know, ever since you came, you just do things to upset me-- things like that.
不，不是经常，但她就是会说，你知道，自从你来了，你就总是做些事惹我生气——诸如此类的话。
When did she first say that to you?
她第一次对你说是什么时候？
Oh, I don't remember. It would-- she would, you know-- she-- yeah, I mean, it would come up, you know?
噢，我不记得了。它会……她会，你知道……她……是的，我是说，它会冒出来，你知道吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
I mean, that would come up a lot, you know? Another thing that would come up a lot was, well, you don't really love us. That's why you didn't want to come with in the first place. I mean, stuff like that has come up so many times.
我是说，这经常冒出来，你知道吗？另一件经常冒出来的事是，好吧，你并不真爱我们。这就是为什么你一开始不想来。我是说，这种话已经出现过很多次了。
I mean, it's just-- I mean, it probably came up like, not too long ago-- probably me as an adult, like, in my 30s, probably. Well, I remember when you didn't want to come with us. You know, it's just like, stuff-- that stuff has come up all the time. It's just-- it's nothing new.
我是说，它只是……我猜它可能在不久前出现过——大概是我成年后，三十多岁的时候，可能吧。好吧，我记得你不想和我们走的时候。你知道，这只是……那些事一直都在出现。这……这没什么新鲜的。
I had no idea my mom had said those things. It felt to me like that was just a harsh thing to say to a kid here, holding something against Dayana, this thing she said when she was so little. But I also realized how much of a scar that was for my mom.
我完全不知道妈妈说过这些话。对我来说，对一个孩子说这种严厉的话，把Dayana小时候说的一句话一直记恨在心，感觉太糟糕了。但也意识到这对我的妈妈来说是多大的伤疤。
When we were teenagers, Dayana was always so busy. I never got as much time as I wanted. It still is sort of that way. I have to book her in advance just to hang out with her.
当我们是青少年时，Dayana总是很忙。我从来没得到过我想要的时间。现在还是有点这样。我得提前预约才能和她出去玩。
I never really understood it, but it makes more sense now, how Dayana kind of turned away from home and started throwing herself into work. She got her first job at 15 so she could pay her own way more and help the household. When she was in high school, it seemed like all she did was study. College, too-- she had a full load of courses and a couple of jobs.
我从来没真正理解过，但这现在更有道理了，Dayana如何开始背离家庭，开始投身于工作。她在15岁时有了第一份工作，这样她就能更多地自立，并帮助家庭。当她在高中时，她似乎整天都在学习。大学也是——她课业繁重，还兼职几份工作。
Well, yeah.
嗯，是的。
Why did you feel you had to be the perfect kid?
为什么你觉得你必须成为完美的孩子？
I-- I don't know. I-- I don't know. I just wanted mom and dad to love me. I got here late, right?
我……我不知道。我……我不知道。我只是想让爸妈爱我。我来晚了，对吧？
I got here when I was eight years old. They didn't really have a relationship with me. So I wanted them to love me.
我八岁时才到这里。他们和我没有真正的感情。所以我想要他们爱我。
When Dayana said, I got here late, it just cut me apart. It's like she's blaming herself-- like she had an appointment, and she messed it all up, and showed up late. I've always known my sister and I had different experiences, but I'm only now realizing just how different.
当Dayana说，“我来晚了”，这简直让我心碎。就好像她在责备自己——就像她有个预约，结果搞砸了，迟到了。我一直知道我和姐姐有不同的经历，但我现在才意识到它们有多么不同。
Recently, I noticed, for example, that my mom has always used with me the less formal and more intimate form of vos. Dayana, instead, has always been addressed as usted, which automatically puts a distance between them. I talked with my mom about this, and she said she didn't consciously do it.
最近我注意到，例如，我妈妈一直对我使用不那么正式和更亲密的“vos”称呼。相反，对Dayana一直使用“usted”，这自动在她们之间建立了一道距离。我和妈妈谈过这件事，她说她不是有意识这样做的。
I believe it, but looking back, she also said, maybe she did that because ever since the separation, she's felt Dayana no longer belonged to her. Also, in almost every sibling squabble, my mom took my side, which turned the three of us into this uncomfortable little triangle. The two of them would fight so much, I'd get anxious and try to play the peacemaker. It didn't always work.
我相信，但回想起来，她也说，也许她那样做是因为自离别以后，她觉得Dayana不再属于她了。而且，在几乎每次姐妹争吵中，我妈妈都站在我这边，这把我们三人变成了一个不舒服的小三角。她们俩吵得很凶，我会感到焦虑，并试图扮演和事佬。但这并不总是有用。
They yelled at each other, got mad at me for taking the other side, and I'd end up feeling like I let them both down in some way. The older we got, the worse it felt. As we were talking, my producer, Nadia Reiman, asked Dayana if she could think of examples of how she and I were treated differently. She had a hard time deciding where to start.
她们对彼此大喊大叫，因为我站在另一边而对我生气，我最终感觉以某种方式辜负了她们两人。我们越长大，感觉越糟糕。当我们交谈时，我的制片人Nadia Reiman问Dayana是否能举出她和我受到不同对待的例子。她很难决定从哪里开始。
OK, well, first, they-- you know, they bought me a car, and I was expected to pay car insurance. Cindy got a car, Cindy got her car paid for, her insurance paid for. Whenever I needed an oil change, I took care of it. I changed the tires, I did everything. Whenever Cindy needed an oil change, dad would go do it for her.
好的，好吧，首先，他们……你知道，他们给我买了辆车，我需要支付车险。Cindy得到了一辆车，Cindy的车钱被付了，她的保险被付了。每当我需要换机油时，我自己搞定。我换轮胎，我做一切。每当Cindy需要换机油时，爸爸会去帮她做。
In college, I had to pay for school. I had to work to pay for school. Cindy went to college, Cindy got everything paid for. Not only that, but she got spending money. Not only that, but she ran up a phone bill. They paid for that. They didn't-- they didn't help me at all for undergrad.
在大学里，我得自己付学费。我得工作来支付学费。Cindy上大学，Cindy得到了一切资助。不仅如此，她还有零花钱。不仅如此，她还欠下了电话费。他们都付了。他们……他们本科时根本没帮我。
My mom says if Dayana remembers it that way, she must be right, though my parents did help her with grad school. And I know it's easy for some of this to sound like normal sibling stuff-- older kid, little sister stuff. But one of the hardest parts of this is that it's hard for Dayana and me to tell what was about her separation and what wasn't.
我妈妈说如果Dayana记得是那样，那她一定是对的，虽然我父母确实在她读研时帮了她。我知道让这一切听起来像是正常的姐妹琐事很容易——大孩子，小妹妹那一套。但最难的部分之一是Dayana和我很难分辨哪些是关于她的离别，哪些不是。
It would have been so easy for Dayana to resent me, to be so mad at how I was treated versus how she was treated, but that didn't happen. Instead, she doubled down on being my greatest protector and advocate. She didn't like it when anyone said anything mean about me, or when the neighborhood kids didn't want to play with me. And in turn, I'd follow her around like a puppy dog.
对Dayana来说，怨恨我、对她受到待遇和我受到的待遇之间的差别感到生气本来是很容易的，但那并没有发生。相反，她加倍努力成为我最伟大的保护者和拥护者。她不喜欢任何人说我的坏话，或者邻居孩子不想和我玩。反过来，我像只小狗一样跟在她身后。
When we talked about this recently, I kept asking her, really? You never resented me? But in this very reasonable Dayana way, she said, no, it wasn't you. You were just a kid-- but so was she.
当我们最近谈到这个时，我一直问她，真的吗？你从来没怨恨过我？但以这种非常理性的Dayana方式，她说，没有，那不是你的错。你只是个孩子——但她也是个孩子啊。
The way the separation-- our beginning-- has shaped the rest of our lives, sometimes, we forget about it. Sometimes, we're caught off guard by it. But it never goes away.
离别——我们的开始——塑造了我们余生的方式，有时我们忘记了它。有时我们对它毫无防备。但它从未消失。
11 years ago, Dayana had a son, Pablo. Soon after Dayana gave birth to him, mom came to stay with Dayana to help her out. Things felt different, like the separation was finally fading.
11年前，Dayana生了个儿子，Pablo。Dayana生下他后不久，妈妈就过来和Dayana住在一起帮忙。感觉不一样了，好像离别终于在消退。
My mom was treating her depression, and was in a much better place. She and Dayana had been able to build a relationship. They'd gotten close.
我妈妈正在治疗她的抑郁症，处于好得多的状态。她和Dayana已经能够建立起一种关系。她们变得亲近了。
One day, my mom was changing Pablo's diaper.
有一天，我妈妈在给Pablo换尿布。
And I remember her specifically telling me, what I didn't do with you, the time that I didn't spend with you, I will make up for it with Pablo.
我记得她具体对我说，我没为你做的，我没花在你身上的时间，我会在Pablo身上补偿。
That was the hope, anyway-- Pablo would help them finally repair this 30-year-old hurt. And then Pablo turned eight.
那至少是希望——Pablo会帮助她们最终修复这30年的伤痛。然后Pablo八岁了。
I remember doing dishes and thinking, wow, Pablo is eight. That's what I came to the US. He really-- he's really just a kid, you know? Why-- why did I go through so much?
我记得洗碗时想到，哇，Pablo八岁了。那是我到美国时的年纪。他真的……他真的只是个孩子，你知道吗？为什么……为什么我经历了那么多？
I started thinking like, OK, you know, I tried so hard. Why was the eight-year-old trying so hard to make her mom happy? Why wasn't it the other way around, right? Why was it me thinking, I'd better be good because they may-- they may send me back?
我开始想，好吧，你知道，我尝试得那么努力。为什么一个八岁的孩子要那么努力地让妈妈开心？为什么不是反过来的，对吧？为什么是我在想，我最好表现好点，因为他们可能……可能会把我送回去？
When Dayana had Pablo, she had a hard time leaving him with his nanny, or even his grandparents. She didn't like being away from him. When Pablo was a toddler, she told me she was looking at getting him microchipped, just to be sure they wouldn't be separated.
当Dayana有了Pablo时，她很难把他留给保姆，甚至留给爷爷奶奶。她不喜欢远离他。当Pablo还是个蹒跚学步的孩子时，她告诉我她正考虑给他植入芯片，只是为了确保他们不会分开。
I was taken aback, and sort of teased her. I was like, he's not a dog, Dayana. Isn't that illegal?
我被惊到了，并开玩笑调侃她。我说，他不是狗，Dayana。那不是违法的吗？
I was really, really paranoid about somebody kidnapping him and taking him away from me. I mean, I had a tracker on him for when he started going to school, when he started going to preschool. There was a little thing, little chain that he would carry. And if-- and I kept telling him, if anything ever happens, anybody ever takes you, or you ever get lost, you push this button, and the police will come.
我真的，真的对有人绑架他并把他带离我身边感到偏执。我是说，他刚开始去学校、去幼儿园时，我给他装了追踪器。有个小东西，他会随身携带的一条小链子。而且如果……如果发生任何事，任何人带走他，或者他走丢了，你就按这个按钮，警察就会来。
I would have dreams that he wasn't with me, that somebody would take him away. And I would be-- and I would look for him, and I would look for him. And then it really, really-- I really started obsessing with it. And I'm still not OK with like, leaving him in the house by himself, or I still need to know where he is at all times.
我会做梦梦到他不在我身边，有人会把他带走。我会……我会找他，我会一直找他。然后它真的，真的……我真的开始对此着迷。而且我仍然无法接受把他独自留在家里，或者我仍然需要随时知道他在哪里。
Dayana is type A in general, but it's hard not to draw a line between her being left behind and this fear that she has of ever being separated from Pablo. I brought it up to her. To my surprise, it was like a light bulb went off. She'd never connected those things. And it made sense to her, the idea that all of this was now shaping Pablo's life, too, a whole generation later.
Dayana总体上是个A型人格，但很难不把她被留下和这种对失去Pablo的恐惧之间划上联系。我向她提到了这一点。令我惊讶的是，就像灯泡亮了一样。她从来没把这些事联系起来。她觉得很有道理，这一切现在也在塑造着Pablo的生活，整整一代人之后。
Two years ago, there was something of a reckoning in my family, at my birthday. It started out as an argument about family history, like about my paternal grandmother's politics. But it became about all of this.
两年前，在我的生日聚会上，我的家庭发生了一次清算。它最初是关于家族史的争论，比如关于我父系祖母的政治立场。但它变成关于这一切。
Everything Dayana was feeling exploded. She finally told my mom how she felt, how she hadn't been treated fairly since she was little. She talked about feeling lonely. She said she still felt like she needed to please mom, and never could.
Dayana感受到的所有东西都爆发了。她终于告诉妈妈她的感受，她自小以来就没有得到公平的对待。她谈到了孤独感。她说她仍然觉得需要取悦妈妈，却永远做不到。
My mom apologized. She asked for forgiveness, but Dayana was so angry. Things haven't been the same since.
我妈妈道歉了。她请求原谅，但Dayana太生气了。从那以后一切都不一样了。
Like, lately, I've just been thinking like, god, if I would have just shut up and kept on living the way I was living, our relationship would still be great. And-- yeah, but I had to-- for some reason, I had to get angry, and I had to get mad.
比如，最近，我一直想，天哪，如果我只是闭嘴，继续按照我之前的方式生活，我们的关系还是会很好。而且……是的，但我不得不……因为某种原因，我必须生气，我必须疯狂。
And I should have just let things go. Like, why? Who cares, right? Like, I'm 46. I have succeeded in life. Why-- who cares? I should have just let things go. Why did I have to bring things up that I wasn't supposed to?
我本应该让事情过去的。比如，为什么？谁在乎呢，对吧？比如，我46岁了。我在生活中取得了成功。为什么……谁在乎？我本该让事情过去的。为什么我一定要提起那些我不该提起的事情？
So do you regret it?
所以你后悔吗？
I do regret it.
我确实后悔了。
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
Yeah, now I do.
是的，现在我后悔了。
What do you think you ultimately want from mom?
你觉得你最终从妈妈那里想要什么？
I just want her back. I just want us to have a relationship.
我只是想要她回来。我只是想让我们拥有这段关系。
But what does that mean, though? Because--
但那意味着什么呢？因为……
I want us to be close. I want her to visit Pablo. I want her to give Pablo the time and the love she didn't give me. That's all I want. That's all I want.
我想要我们亲近。我想要她探望Pablo。我想要她给Pablo她没给我的时间和爱。那就是我想要的全部。那就是我想要的全部。
At that birthday, during that fight, I did something I really hadn't done before-- I changed my role. Finding our way through all of this, I'd always tried to stay neutral, an intermediary. But in this case, I switched. I stood up for Dayana.
在那次生日，在争吵期间，我做了一件我以前真的没做过的事——我改变了我的角色。为了解决这一切，我一直试图保持中立，作为一个调解人。但在这次情况中，我转换了。我支持Dayana。
I stepped in-between them, not as a neutral peacekeeper, but to defend my sister. I've been doing that more and more, lately. Recently, I was reporting and talking to a bunch of moms at the border in Tijuana. They worried they'd be separated from their kids.
我介入她们中间，不是作为一个中立的和事佬，而是为了保卫我的姐姐。最近我越来越多地这样做。最近，我在边境上的提华纳采访了一群母亲。她们担心会和孩子分开。
I got really upset, and kept thinking about Dayana, about how she was left behind for so long. So I called her. I felt compelled to tell her what I'd seen.
我非常难过，一直想到Dayana，想到她被留下那么久。所以我给她打了电话。我感到有义务告诉她我所看到的。
She said she just felt awful for those mothers and their kids. Then, I called my mom. She told me she thought it was irresponsible for these mothers to bring their children with them. It was dangerous, she said, and she insinuated that some of the women were lying about why they were leaving, that this was all a trick to bring kids on a journey they shouldn't be on-- which, because of my reporting, I knew it wasn't true.
她说她为那些母亲和孩子感到难过。然后，我给妈妈打了电话。她说她认为这些母亲带孩子来是不负责任的。她说那是危险的，而且她暗示有些妇女在撒谎，说她们为什么离开，这全是个把孩子带上一段不该有的旅程的诡计——这因为我的报道，我知道不是真的。
It kind of infuriated me. And so I said, but mom, these women don't want to leave their kids behind. You had to make a similar choice when you left Dayana, and I don't think it worked out all that great. As soon as I said it, I felt badly. I still do.
这有点激怒了我。所以我说，但是妈妈，这些女性不想把孩子抛下。你离开Dayana时也必须做出类似的决定，我不认为那结果有多好。我刚说完，就觉得很糟。我现在还是。
Mom was silent. She said, that's completely different. I knew it was a hard thing for mom to hear, but I said it anyway. I felt I needed to-- to stand up for Dayana, in a way, for what she'd been through.
妈妈沉默了。她说，那是完全不同的。我知道这对妈妈来说是很难听的话，但我还是说了。我觉得我需要……以某种方式为Dayana站出来，为她所经历的一切。
My sister and I made a promise to each other recently, that we're going to be there for each other, no matter what. While we try to fix things with our mom, we're also making a new version of our relationship where now, I'm the one looking out for my big sister, Dayana, protecting her as much as she always did for me.
我和姐姐最近向彼此保证，无论发生什么，我们都会互相支持。当我们试图修复和妈妈的关系时，我们也在建立一段新的关系，现在我是那个照顾我大姐Dayana的人，像她一直保护我一样保护她。
Cindy Carcamo is a staff writer at the Los Angeles Times. Coming up, dee dee dah, pa joo wah-- we translate from Sister to English for you. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
Cindy Carcamo是《洛杉矶时报》的专职记者。接下来，dee dee dah, pa joo wah——我们将为你从“姐妹语”翻译成英语。几分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's the BBC News Hour. I'm Bim Adewunmi. Kidding-- it's This American Life. I'm sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's program, "Sisters"-- stories about the worlds sisters create together, and what happens when those worlds are unmade. We've arrived at Sister Act Two: Megan and Sybil.
这是BBC新闻时间。我是Bim Adewunmi。开玩笑的——这是《美国生活》。我是代班主持人Ira Glass。今天的节目，“姐妹”——关于姐妹共同创造的世界的故事，以及当这些世界被拆解时会发生什么。我们到达了姐妹篇第二部：Megan和Sybil。
There's this thing that I read years ago that I think about quite often, and it came up a lot as we were putting together this show. It's a Toni Morrison interview from 2015. And the interviewer, Rachel Kaadzi Ghansah, asked Miss Morrison about her sister, Lois. Were they close? She asked.
我多年前读到过一件事，我经常想到它，在我们准备这期节目时它经常浮现。那是托妮·莫里森2015年的一次采访。采访者Rachel Kaadzi Ghansah问莫里森关于她姐姐Lois的事。她们亲近吗？她问。
And apparently, Toni Morrison gave her an eye roll that she described as, "so sharp it chopped down the question and me." After a long pause, she gave her answer-- my sister? I need her. I think about it because the language is so simple, yet so grand. I get it-- the person you need to that degree that it defines so much of who you are.
显然，托妮·莫里森给了她一个白眼，她形容为“极其尖锐，足以砍断这个问题和采访者本人”。长久的沉默后，她给出了回答——我的姐姐？我需要她。我思考这个，因为语言如此简单，却又如此宏大。我明白了——那个你需要到那种程度的人，定义了你究竟是谁的很大一部分。
The first act of our show was about someone who had spent decades trying to close the gap with her sister because they were apart until she was eight years old. This next story is the reverse-- these sisters, Megan and Sybil Neuringer, were together up through eight. Their separation started when they were nine. Lilly Sullivan has the story.
节目的第一部分关于一个试图缩小与姐姐差距的人，因为她们在八岁前是分离的。这下一个故事刚好相反——这对姐妹，Megan和Sybil Neuringer，她们八岁前一直在一起。她们的分离始于九岁。Lilly Sullivan讲述了这个故事。
The sisters in this story are Megan and Sybil. They're twins-- identical. And when you ask Megan to describe her childhood, ages zero through nine, she doesn't hesitate. She told me it felt like heaven.
这个故事里的姐妹是Megan和Sybil。她们是双胞胎——同卵。当你让Megan描述她的童年，零到九岁，她毫不犹豫。她告诉我感觉就像天堂。
We played so much pretend. We had all these trees in our backyard. And they'd knock down a tree, and the guts of the tree were out in our lawn. And you could see the pulp, the soft like, white pulp of the tree. And it was like, kind of moist.
我们经常假装游戏。我们的后院里有好多树。他们会砍倒一棵树，树的内部就暴露在草坪上。你可以看到树的果肉，那种柔软的，像白色的果肉。而且它看起来，有点湿润。
And we played like we were eating like, the chicken meat of the tree. And we thought this was like, the most incredible discovery-- that like, oh my god, the tree is made of chicken meat, and we're eating the chicken! Like, I think we ate tree pulp.
我们假装在吃树的“鸡肉”。我们认为这是最不可思议的发现——天哪，树是由鸡肉做的，我们正在吃鸡肉！我觉得我们真的吃了树肉。
We had a song that we would sing with each other. And it was like, our twin chant. And we would like, sing it all the time.
我们有一首经常互相唱的歌。就像，我们的双胞胎圣歌。我们经常唱它。
And we would just go, (SINGING) dee-dee da, pa-joo wah, dee-dee da, pa-joo wah. I have no idea what it means, but I know what it feels like.
我们就那样唱，（唱歌）dee-dee da, pa-joo wah, dee-dee da, pa-joo wah。我完全不知道它是什么意思，但我知道它是什么感觉。
Huh.
哈。
Because we did it in front of the mirror together. We liked to see-- it's funny, like-- that there was something-- that's like, occurring to me. We liked to see ourselves as twins in front of the mirror when we did the chant-- like, to see, oh my gosh, there you are, and there I am. There I am, and there you are. But you look like me, and I look like you. And it's the same.
因为我们在镜子前一起做。我们喜欢看——真有趣，就像……有什么……正在浮现在我脑海。我们喜欢在照镜子时作为双胞胎看那个圣歌——就像是看，噢天哪，那是你，那是我是我。这是我，那是你。但你看向我，我看向你。都是一样的。
Do you remember having like, an opinion about her? Like, what did you think she was like?
你还记得对她有什么看法吗？比如，你觉得她是什么样的人？
Oh, I've-- I-- I loved her. It sounds weird, but it was like, so-- it was like my first foray into like, romance, but it wasn't romance. But it was like, pure love. I was like, in love with my sister.
噢，我……我爱她。听起来很奇怪，但这就像我第一次涉足浪漫，但它不是浪漫。但它是那种纯粹的爱。我就像是爱上了我的姐妹。
Sybil died when they were nine years old. And it's only recently that Megan's really started talking about Sybil at all. For decades, it's been too hard. It wasn't only that she died, it was also the way that they were separated.
Sybil在九岁时去世了。直到最近，Megan才开始真正谈论Sybil。几十年来，这太难了。不仅仅是因为她去世了，还因为她们分离的方式。
It was really sudden. She told me it was September, the beginning of fifth grade. The school day had just ended. They were walking with a group of kids, and stopped at a hot dog stand.
真的很突然。她告诉我那是九月，五年级刚开学。放学时间刚过。她们正和一群孩子走在一起，在一个热狗摊停下。
And while we were at the stand-- I don't know why-- Sybil just ran across the street. And when she ran across the street, she got hit by a car. And I saw it happen.
当我们在摊位时——我不知道为什么——Sybil跑过了街。当她跑过街时，被一辆车撞了。我亲眼看到了。
And I screamed, just-- I just was screaming. I didn't even know I was screaming, but somebody came and stopped me from screaming. And I tried to run out into the street, and somebody stopped me.
我尖叫，只是……我不停尖叫。我甚至不知道我在尖叫，但有人过来阻止我尖叫。我试图冲向大街，有人阻止了我。
And she was lying in the street. And I remember there was this mechanic, or some guy in like, a dirty outfit. And he had a like, oily rag, and he went to her to wipe the blood off her forehead. And he's putting this dirty rag on her head, and I-- I didn't like that.
她躺在街上。我记得有一个修理工，或者是个穿着脏衣服的男人。他拿着一块油腻的抹布，走到她身边去擦她额头上的血。他把脏抹布放在她头上，我……我不喜欢那样。
The ambulance took Sybil to the hospital. Megan went home and waited, alone. She desperately wanted to see Sybil, but her parents didn't let her. So she never saw Sybil again.
救护车把Sybil送到了医院。Megan回家独自等待。她极度想见Sybil，但父母没让她去。所以她再也没见到Sybil。
Megan remembers when her mom told her they were going to unplug Sybil, how angry she was, and how she begged them not to.
Megan记得妈妈告诉她她们要拔掉Sybil的插头时，她有多生气，她有多哀求他们不要那样做。
If your sister is your whole world, what happens when she's gone?
如果你的姐妹就是你的整个世界，当她离开时会发生什么？
I was born with Sybil. There was always Sybil. And so when she was gone, I felt so weird. I felt-- that's the word. I just felt like, ugh, this is not right.
我和Sybil一起出生。总是Sybil。所以当她离开时，我感到很奇怪。我感到……就是那个词。我只觉得，哎，这不对劲。
Without Sybil, Megan really didn't know who she was or who she should be. So she started inventing ways to keep Sibyl around.
没有了Sybil，Megan真的不知道自己是谁，或者应该成为谁。所以她开始发明各种方式把Sybil留在身边。
This is sort of where I was like, I have to do something really exceptional and remarkable with my life. I'm responsible for whatever Sybil didn't get to have, so I'll live that life, and I'll live my life. And I'll combine them, and it's going to be like, ultra-Megatron life. All the pressure was on for me to have the most amazing life of all time. I like, had to be the best.
这有点像我意识到，我必须在生活中做些极其卓越和非凡的事情。我负责Sybil没能得到的一切，所以我过那种生活，我也过我自己的生活。我把它们结合起来，那会像是某种“超级Megatron生活”。所有的压力都在我身上，让我过上有史以来最惊人的生活。我像是必须成为最棒的。
Had you been like that before?
你之前是那样的人吗？
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
No, I was pretty messy. Every teacher, when you'd get like, reviewed for like, how Megan was in class, was like, Megan is exceptionally bright, curious, great kid. Not a perfectionist-- sloppy, very undisciplined.
不，我挺邋遢的。每个老师，当评论Megan在课堂上怎么样时，都是说，Megan极其聪明、好奇、好孩子。不是完美主义者——邋遢，非常不守纪律。
She became disciplined. She also started doing all the things Sybil was no longer doing-- the things Sybil loved, like her ballet classes. Sybil had loved ballet. Megan had quit years earlier-- too strict. The leotards were too girly for her, and it bugged her how the teacher would always be telling her to pull her tush in.
她变得守纪律了。她还开始做Sybil不再做的事情——Sybil喜欢的事情，比如她的芭蕾舞课。Sybil喜欢芭蕾。Megan早在几年前就退出了——太严格了。紧身衣对她来说太“女孩气”了，老师总是告诉她要把臀部收进去，这让她很烦。
But after she died, I started taking ballet lessons, and I danced.
但在她去世后，我开始上芭蕾课，我跳舞。
Hmm.
嗯。
Ballet and jazz, all of it. And I have to tell you, I didn't like it. [LAUGHS] I didn't like it.
芭蕾和爵士，所有的一切。我得告诉你，我不喜欢它。[笑声] 我不喜欢它。
Sybil had written poetry, so Megan started writing poetry, too. That one, she liked, though-- sitting at her desk in their room, composing in her journal the way Sybil had.
Sybil写过诗，所以Megan也开始写诗。那个她喜欢，虽然——坐在她们房间的书桌前，像Sybil那样在日记里构思。
In my journal, I would write, we're going to make it. We're making it. We are.
在日记里，我会写，我们要成功了。我们要成功了。我们会的。
I wrote as we-- me and Sybil. We're going to get an A on this test, you know? We're going to ace the SATs. We're-- we have to. We have to make it. Making it. We are making it.
我以“我们”写——我和Sybil。我们这次考试要得A，你知道吗？我们要拿下SAT。我们要……我们必须。我们必须成功。成功。我们正在成功。
Making it meant if there was any opportunity to achieve, she owed it to Sybil to excel. So a few months after Sybil died, there was this thing at school-- the Presidential Fitness Award, one of those national fitness tests they made lots of kids do back in the '80s that everyone seems to remember with a sense of shame and failure-- how long could you hold the sitting V, dangling in front of your classmates in gym, trying to do a pull-up?
“成功”意味着如果有任何取得成就的机会，她必须为了Sybil而胜出。所以Sybil去世几个月后，学校里有件事——总统体能奖，那是80年代学校让很多孩子做的那些全国体能测试之一，每个人似乎都带着羞耻和失败感回忆起它——你在体育课上在同学面前吊着，试图做一个引体向上，你能坚持做坐姿V形支撑多久？
I decided, well, I can be anything, and I'm going to get the Presidential Physical Fitness Award. I have to. I started training for it, basically, with my mom. I'm like, I have to practice the standing broad jump because you have to get a certain amount.
我决定，好吧，我可以成为任何东西，而且我要拿到总统体能奖。我必须拿到。我基本上和我妈妈开始为它训练。我像，我必须练习立定跳远，因为你必须达到一定的距离。
And there was like, the nine-minute mile. This was like, so hard for me-- like, running, oh my god, a nine-minute mile. And I remember when I was competing for it, I started feeling so tired in my lungs that I started hyperventilating, because I'd put so much pressure on myself, too. And I was hyperventilating, and I started crying.
还有九分钟跑完一英里。这对我也太难了——比如跑步，天哪，九分钟跑完一英里。我记得当我为它竞争时，我的肺部感到非常疲惫，开始过度换气，因为我给自己施加了太大压力。我在过度换气，开始哭泣。
And I remember these two classmates, these boys were helping me off the track. And I'm crying, and I'm letting myself down, and I'm like, letting Sybil down, and I'm not going to get it. And I-- they're like, helping me off the track, and I pushed them away. And I finished like, crying and hyperventilating.
我记得那两个同学，那些男孩帮我下了跑道。我在哭，我在让自己失望，我觉得我在让Sybil失望，我拿不到它了。我……他们帮我离开跑道，我推开了他们。我最终就是在那儿哭泣和过度换气。
This is literally like, the story of my life. I'm not naturally good at it, I'm pretty close to quitting. Somebody's like, you should quit, and then I'm like, actually, let me finish, crying and hyperventilating, and like, try to get what I want. But my name was up on that wall, and I still have the T-shirt from fifth grade.
这就是我生活的真实写照。我天生不擅长，我离放弃很近。有人说，你应该放弃，然后我就会说，实际上，让我做完，一边哭一边过度换气，试图得到我想要的。但我的名字被挂在那堵墙上，而且我还留着那件五年级的T恤。
That first year after Sybil died, Megan doesn't remember letting herself cry about Sybil. She didn't talk about her. She felt like if she started crying, she'd never stop. She'd cry so much that she'd end up in a mental hospital.
Sybil去世后的第一年，Megan不记得自己允许过因为Sybil哭泣。她不谈论她。她觉得如果她开始哭，就永远停不下来。她会哭到被送进精神病院。
As she got older, she'd get stuck on certain thoughts-- that she should have been the one who died, that Sybil was the better twin. She often thought about killing herself, but thought, what an insult to Sybil. Her parents weren't much help with any of this.
随着年龄增长，她会陷入某些想法——她应该才是那个死去的人，Sybil是那个更好的双胞胎。她经常想自杀，但又想，那是对Sybil的侮辱。父母对这些没什么帮助。
They talked about sending her to a therapist, but Megan didn't want to go, and they didn't force her. So they just never talked about any of it.
他们谈过送她去见治疗师，但Megan不想去，他们也没强迫她。所以他们就从没谈论过这件事。
Like, there was no, but what does Megan want? But what about Megan? Like-- which is fine. Truly, like, my parents were living like, a full nightmare.
比如，没有“Megan想要什么？”或者“Megan怎么样？”……这没关系，真的，我父母当时过着完全的噩梦。
My parents were so sad. Everybody was so sad. And it was like, well, I can't be.
我父母太难过了。每个人都太难过了。这就像，好吧，我不能这样。
She made a point of trying to act like everything was fine, to hold it together. And as she got into high school, she got even more intense, doing this thing she sometimes calls double living-- living a life that's not just the best, but twice as good as a normal life, for Sybil.
她刻意表现得好像一切都很好，保持坚强。随着进入高中，她变得更强烈，做着她有时称为“双重生活”的事——过着一种生活，不仅仅是最好的，而且是两倍于正常生活的优秀，为了Sybil。
The destination was like, to go to the best college and to have the best life. Making it-- we were going to make it.
目的地就像是去最好的大学，过最好的生活。成功——我们要成功。
By the time she's an adult, that voice in her head putting pressure on her, it just kind of became Megan's personality, how she thought about herself.
当她成年时，她脑子里施加压力的那个声音，就变成了Megan的个性，她思考自己的方式。
Like, I have to get this right. It has to be perfect. It can't be stupid, it can't just be fun. It has to mean something.
比如，我必须把这个搞定。它必须是完美的。它不能愚蠢，不能仅仅是好玩。它必须有意义。
So is this something you feel like you wouldn't have done if you weren't doing it for Sybil in some way?
所以这是你觉得如果不是为了Sybil，你就不会做的事吗？
That's a really hard question to answer because I don't-- like, who am I? Who am I if Sybil hadn't passed away? I-- that's something I would love to know.
那是一个很难回答的问题，因为我不知道……我是谁？如果Sybil没有去世，我是谁？那是我很想知道的事情。
But I honestly don't know because I don't know if this ambition would have been here in some ways, anyway. Like, I really don't know.
但我真的不知道，因为我不知道这种野心在某些方面是否会以某种方式存在。比如，我真的不知道。
Yeah. What do you think Sybil would have-- would think if she like, were seeing you pushing yourself to do things that were painful for you like that, all those years? What do you think she would say?
是的。你觉得Sybil……如果她看到你为了Sybil做那些对你来说痛苦的事情，这么多年来，她会怎么想？你觉得她会说什么？
I understand your question, and I don't know why I always have this like, instant reluctance when people ask me, what do you think Sybil would think or say? And other people have asked. And I think I-- I think I get so just-- it's not your fault, it's that I think I instantly get outraged that I have to answer for her.
我理解你的问题，我不知道为什么每当人们问我“你觉得Sybil会怎么想或说什么”时，我总是有一种瞬间的抗拒。其他人也问过。我觉得我……我觉得我变得如此……这不是你的错，是我觉得我立刻对必须代替她回答感到愤怒。
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
I don't like it. Like, I don't like having to imagine. I'm mad that she can't answer you.
我不喜欢它。比如，我不喜欢必须想象。我很生气，她无法回答你。
And I think maybe my reaction is just a little bit nuts. I think it's a normal question. Like, I think it's a really natural question.
也许我的反应有点疯狂。我觉得这是一个正常的问题。比如，我觉得这是一个非常自然的问题。
But to like, try to imagine her reaction to adult Megan-- in a lot of ways, she's frozen for me, at nine. She is. Sybil's nine. She died at nine. Everything else is an invention.
但尝试去想象她对成年Megan的反应——在很多方面，她对我来说是冻结在九岁。她是。Sybil永远是九岁。她在九岁去世了。其他的一切都是发明。
It's only recently that Megan's started trying to sort out who she is outside of Sybil. This began a few years ago, when her mom was dying of cancer. Megan was with her the whole time, through hospice, and all those days when her mom was in and out of consciousness, on morphine, in that middle place between living and dying.
直到最近，Megan才开始试图理清她自己是谁，而不是Sybil的延续。这始于几年前，当她妈妈癌症垂死时。Megan全程陪着她，经过临终关怀，经过所有那些日子，当她妈妈意识不清、注射吗啡、处于生与死的中间地带时。
And she, at one point, was calling me Sybil a lot. And I said, at one point, no, mom, I'm Megan. Sybil died. And she corrected me, and she said, no, Megan died. We lost Megan. Sybil stayed.
有一次，她一直在叫我Sybil。有一次我说，不，妈妈，我是Megan。Sybil去世了。她纠正我，她说，不，Megan去世了。我们失去了Megan。Sybil留了下来。
And-- and I remember, you know, I was kind of shocked, but not because it hurt my feelings, but that maybe she's right. Maybe Megan did die, and Sybil did stay. And this whole time, you know, yeah, I'm the dead one.
我记得，你知道，我当时很震惊，但不是因为伤了我的心，而是也许她是正确的。也许Megan确实去世了，而Sybil留了下来。而这段时间，你知道，是的，我是死掉的那个。
Megan had thought that if she could do the right things, then she might start feeling less dead, but it wasn't working. So just in the past few years, she's started to let go of this project to live for Sybil. It hasn't been easy, but she feels more like herself.
Megan曾经认为如果她能做正确的事，她可能会感到没那么“死气沉沉”，但这没用。所以就在过去几年里，她开始放下这个为Sybil而活的计划。这不容易，但她感觉更像自己了。
She's put down some of that anger she's always had about the injustice of Sybil's death. And that's cleared the way for her to feel more like she did when they were together. It surprised her, she said. She feels close to Sybil again. She loves her.
她放下了她一直以来对Sybil死亡不公的一些愤怒。这为她感觉更像在一起时那样清扫了道路。她说这让她感到惊讶。她感觉又和Sybil亲近了。她爱她。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our show. Before we go, there's this passage from Housekeeping, a novel about two sisters written by Marilynne Robinson, published in 1980. It nails something about sisters that I just really identify with-- the kind of inadvertent performance sisters sometimes put on that people notice and are drawn to.
Lilly Sullivan是我们节目的制片人之一。在结束之前，有段来自《管家》(Housekeeping)的选段，那是Marilynne Robinson写于1980年的一部关于两个姐妹的小说。它精准捕捉了姐妹间某种我非常有共鸣的东西——姐妹们有时会无意中进行的表演，人们会注意到并被吸引。
She writes, "Having a sister or a friend is like sitting at night in a lighted house. Those outside can watch you if they want, but you need not see them. You simply say, here are the perimeters of our attention. If you prowl around under the windows till the crickets go silent, we will pull the shades.
她写道：“拥有一个姐妹或朋友就像在夜晚坐在亮着的房子里。外面的人如果想看就能看你，但你不必看他们。你只需说，这就是我们注意力的边界。如果你在窗下徘徊直到蟋蟀噤声，我们会拉下窗帘。
If you wish us to suffer your envious curiosity, you must permit us not to notice it. Anyone with one solid human bond is that smug. And it is the smugness, as much as the comfort and safety, that lonely people covet and admire."
如果你希望我们忍受你那嫉妒的好奇心，你必须允许我们不去注意到它。任何拥有一个坚实人类纽带的人都是那样自鸣得意。而这种自鸣得意，就像舒适和安全一样，是孤独者所觊觎和钦佩的。”
Our show today was produced by Laura Starecheski and Lilly Sullivan. The people who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Alissa Shipp, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, senior editor David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Cindy and Dayana Carcamo's mother, Reed Johnson, Luz Paz, Cora, Nick Fainbarg, Sylvie and Brian Malamet, Maggie and Lila Margulies, Noga Newberg, and my big sister, Ade Adewunmi. Fact checking by Andrea López-Cruzado and Christopher Swetala.
我们今天的节目由Laura Starecheski和Lilly Sullivan制作。参与制作今天节目的人包括Elna Baker, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ari Saperstein, Alissa Shipp, Matt Tierney, 和 Diane Wu。我们的主编是Sarah Abdurrahman，高级编辑David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。今天特别感谢Cindy和Dayana Carcamo的母亲，Reed Johnson, Luz Paz, Cora, Nick Fainbarg, Sylvie 和 Brian Malamet, Maggie 和 Lila Margulies, Noga Newberg, 以及我的大姐，Ade Adewunmi。事实核查由Andrea López-Cruzado和Christopher Swetala完成。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. And there's videos, and lists of favorite shows, and tons of other stuff there, too. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过700集的档案。那里还有视频，最爱节目列表，以及大量其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。
Special thanks to our regular host, Ira Glass. He's got this ritual before every interview-- he goes to the bathroom, looks straight in the mirror, and has a pep talk conversation with himself-- oh, it's a good thing you're smart. I'm glad you're smart. Yeah, I am smart.
特别感谢我们的常规主持人Ira Glass。他在每次采访前都有个仪式——他去洗手间，直视镜子，对自己进行谈话激励——噢，你真聪明，我很高兴你很聪明。是的，我很聪明。
I'm Bim Adewunmi. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Bim Adewunmi。下周我们将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。